no I don't agree with that that 2015
confrontation on the Yale campus between
Nicholas Christakis a sociologist and
physician and protesting students was
part of a controversy over how to dress
up on Halloween it all started a week
earlier when the school's intercultural
Affairs Council sent an email
encouraging members of the community to
be careful not to offend their fellow
students with culturally and racially
insensitive costumes Christakis his wife
Erica an expert in early childhood
education at the University responded
with her own thoughts
is there no room anymore for a child or
young person to be a little bit
obnoxious a little bit inappropriate or
provocative or yes offensive American
universities she wrote have become
places of censure and prohibition
students said that by sending her email
Christakis had failed to create a safe
space at Yale silliman College where she
served as associate master Nicholas
Christakis jumped into the fray
defending his wife's email and then he
tried to engage in a dialogue with
protesters scenes of students shouting
at Christakis one of yells most
respected faculty members went viral do
not interrupt me I was not angry and now
I want your job to be taken from you I
don't want you to have this job I am
disgusted knowing that you work at Yale
University where I will get my degree
where I will look back and think I have
to argue with you Christakis not only
held on to his tenured professorship but
three years later he was awarded this
sterling professorship yells hi as
faculty honor and his confrontation with
students kicked off an ongoing national
debate about freedom of speech political
correctness and millennial sensitivity
on college campuses and homily or the
fact that we prefer to connect with
people we resemble have fundamental
significance as a sociologist the 56
year old Christakis is no stranger to
highly-charged group interactions his
new book is blueprint the evolutionary
origins of a good society which argues
that our genetic makeup predisposes us
to favor peaceful interaction and
respectful coexistence over angry
violent mob rules I have a vision of us
as people that actually privileges our
common humanity that is interested not
in what is different among us but what
is the same i sat down with Christakis
to talk about his theory that what
unites us as humans is stronger than
what divides us the power of evolution
as an explanatory system for society and
whether enlightenment values such as
civil discourse and intellectual freedom
are still respected in our nation's
colleges and universities Nicholas
Christakis thanks for talking to Reason
thank you so much for having me Nick
what's the elevator pitch of your book I
think the elevator pitch is that for far
too long in my opinion scientists have
been focused on the dark side of our
humanity on our propensity to violence
and selfishness and tribalism and
mendacity and they have overlooked what
I think is the bright side the fact that
we have evolved these wonderful
qualities this ability to love each
other and befriend each other and
cooperate with each other and teach and
learn from each other for example and my
argument would be that on balance the
benefits of a connected life must have
outweighed the costs or we wouldn't be
living the way we are living we wouldn't
be social animals if whenever I came
near you you murdered me or you lied to
me or you harmed me in some way or you
took advantage of me I wouldn't stay
connected to you we wouldn't live as a
social species instead we would be a
solitary species but we're not so the
advantages had to be more than the
disadvantages this is a book of
evolutionary sociology and blueprint a
blueprint is the controlling metaphor of
the book explain what you mean by a
blueprint so I think what I mean by
blueprint is is that natural selection
has shaped a kind of fundamental way in
which we go about living socially most
people nowadays are familiar with the
idea that natural selection and our
genes guide the structure and function
of our bodies and people increasingly
are also aware of the fact that natural
selection and genetics can guide the
structure and function of our minds you
know whether you are risk averse or have
wanderlust or have a musical taste in
music for example your genes play some
role in that but what I argue is that
natural selection and our genes also
play a role not only in the structure
and function of our
body's not only in the structure and
function of our minds and hence of hence
our behaviors but also the structure and
function of our society so this is this
is like we're pack animals not exactly
not just that we're pack animals that
actually natural selection has equipped
us with a whole set of fundamental
qualities like the capacity for love or
the capacity for friendship and that in
the interest in those things or the
taste in in cooperation or in teaching
and learning from each other so we have
this suite of traits these actually good
qualities that have been shaped by
natural selection that allow us to live
together in specific ways you you right
at one point about a social suite of
kind of characteristics or
predispositions but you're also I mean
when people start talking about
evolution as the explanatory system for
human behavior a lot of times the radar
goes up because you're not saying that
people are genetically determined in an
absolute way you talked about pre-wiring
rather than hard yes what what is the
distinction there and why is that very
important well think about the fact that
you might have a set of genes that
specify how how tall you might be when
you grow up but of course if I raised
you in an environment in which you're
starved you'll never achieve the height
that you are let's say pre-wired to
achieve so there's no doubt the
environment plays an enormous role in
shaping the way you express a variety of
traits so just just because people might
have evolved to be cooperative species
if you are spend your whole life in a
war-torn environment you're gonna be
quite understandably very suspicious of
other people so the argument is is that
we have were equipped with a with
certain capacities which we are prone to
manifest and express but those can be
reshaped now I do argue and I do believe
that I mean both nature and nurture are
crucially important I'm not a strict
determinist and I talk about that but um
but I do argue that we have been deluded
by looking around the world and seeing
all the tremendous variation and how
people dress themselves and how they
govern themselves and and and what
sports they play and all of these traits
you know anyone who's travelled has has
been abroad and has seen oh it smells
different here and the food is different
here and the people dressed different
here and they look different here
but I would argue that actually once you
spend some time in that country you
begin to see that oh my god they love
their partners like we do they love
their children like we do they they have
friendships like we do they they're like
us these you you have a kind of an
appreciation for our shared humanity
which comes very quickly and so my
argument is that we wrongly are deluded
by what I would characterize as a thin
veneer of civilization over a much more
fundamental bigger deeper more important
set of principles that undergird how we
live right you right towards the end of
the book modern societies are just the
patina of civilization on top of this
evolutionary blueprint so that that
allows you to explain variation but also
commonality what rehearse the history
though of like we you know at least
since the beginning of the 20th century
we seem to bounce back and forth between
people who are strict to terminus who
will say well everything is genetic and
you know that's it and you know good
luck if you you're born dumb you're
never gonna get smart or whatever to
people who say no we're absolute blank
slates are you saying that we are now
getting to a point where we're we're a
little bit more grown-up I wouldn't
always own you know say it's a little
bit of each or these things work in
connection I would hope so I despair
lately of the capacity of any kind of
intellectual conversation in our society
that tolerates shades of grey and nuance
but yes I think that's exactly right I
mean I think that we which both it's
both nature and nurture there's also
some more subtle ideas that people might
want to understand which is which it's
it can be a nurturer via nature for
example we may be equipped with the
capacity to reshape the environment
around us let me the trivial example of
this might be you might be the kind of
person who's friendlier than others and
you will go about creating a friendly
environment for yourself or you might be
the kind of person let's pick a simpler
toya example you might be the kind of
person that's very cold intolerant you
don't like the cold and so you start
lighting fires you build fires for
yourself to reshape the environment
around you so the environment around you
is different because as it were of your
genes so it's both it's it and and
they're even more complicated ideas
ideas that have to do with something
known as gene-culture co-evolution
so the best example of this the simplest
example the most famous example is the
example of lactase persistence lactase
is an enzyme that digests lactose a
sugar in milk and in ancestrally in
humans the lactase was only present when
we were infants when we were suckling at
our mother's breast and drinking milk
once we were weaned there was no reason
for us to the capacity to digest milk
because there was no milk
we had no milk in our diet but then
around 10,000 years ago we domesticate
animals all of a sudden in our
environment because of our culture
because of our cultural invention of
domesticating animals now milk is
available for us to eat therefore the
ability to digest lactose into adulthood
becomes advantageous and scientists have
shown that between the last three
thousand and nine thousand years
multiple times mutations have arisen in
the human line that make us capable of
digesting milk now what's amazing about
this is is that it suggests that
cultural inventions of our making are
reshaping evolution in historical time
so for example when we invent cities we
create a new environment for ourselves
which may advantage certain individuals
people with brains that make them better
able to live in cities suddenly might be
fitter
in a Darwinian sense precisely because
we've culturally have invented cities so
there may be many many things you know I
may we may all be more nearsighted
myself included because of medieval lens
grinders made it possible for us to
survive yeah I'm wearing contacts oh no
idea how humans existed without you
would've been fake eyeglass yes you
would have been long gone and have no
progeny and that would be the end of
your life to pursue that a little bit
more you get towards in one chapter the
book you talk about things specific not
even about kind of cultural things like
cities or that kind of technology but
things like germline engineering
artificial intelligence the way the
internet or printing changed things talk
a little bit about how that kind of
technology changes things and and should
we would should we be worried about this
or is it this is just what we don't I
mean it's clearly the case that our
technological innovations have always
changed the Fitness the evolutionary
environment for example when we invent
fire when we do
you know when we learn how to make fire
our bodies are do we have smaller teeth
now and shorter intestines because we
mastered fire and therefore could cook
our food which made it possible for us
to extract more calories from the food
and not have to chew it as much or have
the food spend as much time in our
intestine in other words we pre digest
the food by heating it okay so or we
invented stone tools right you invent
stone tools it makes different body
types better able that can handle
weapons for example we invent weapons or
cities as we discussed so it's clearly
the case that across time we humans have
made innovations that have left their
mark on our bodies and our genes it's
too early to tell with things like the
internet or artificial intelligence but
I have no doubt that some scientists ten
thousand years ago will look back at
when we when we would you know when we
invented the internet and said that you
know for example here's an important
feature for since time immemorial it's
been very important for me to remember
who people are and whether there are my
friends or enemies but if I have Google
glass and I can walk around and it will
use facial detection algorithms to
automatically detect people bring up
their biographies and say friend or foe
then that brain capacity that used to be
important in me no longer is important
and humans will evolve in a different
direction I think that's quite likely
same with artificial intelligence in our
midst you know if we started getting
robotic intelligence in our midst this
technology will reshape our social
interactions in ways that are probably
bad but could also be good or they just
become a fact of nature then we we have
to deal with that's right you know let's
drill down a little bit on this you know
a fascinating question of so we have a
common humanity which is what I
shouldn't be a surprise I mean it seems
like we used to believe that obviously
but then we have massive individual or
group variation talk about the ways that
some cultures are monogamous polyandrous
polygynous how do you explain that if
we're really all we really want is to be
loved yes so so I think what lies at the
core of this so you we look around the
world for example I mean intimacy is a
really fundamental and important part of
human behavior we well it was until
pornhub well porno
well actually it's interesting I think
porn is a kind of it's a kind of
hyperactive expression of a fundamental
human impetus so and that just to be
clear you're not you're not being paid
by pornhub just I'm not yes give me five
bonus way and universal it's part of
that social support in Roman times yeah
the porn goes way way back but yeah so
so what we do want intimacy that that's
a route no it's not that we want and we
want attachment okay so there's
something we are species is unusual in
that we have evolved the capacity not
just to have sex with each other but to
be attached to each other we have a kind
of monogamy actually now 90% of bird
species are monogamous relatively few
mammalian species are monogamous
monogamy is a kind of sustained social
interaction with your mate if you think
about it we don't need to have that
quality to be able to reproduce but we
do we stick around and we feel we have a
sentiment about our partners this is
also seen in in certain other animals
certain other mammals certain primates
in certain long-lived certain other long
live mammals we can go there but anyway
we feel this way now what's interesting
though is that culturally we have a
tremendous variation in the kind of
marital systems we manifest so most
societies historically have been
polygynous one man many women one
percent have been polyandrous one woman
many man and there have been a goodly
number of monogamous societies all of us
and in individuals who practice monogamy
- but in all of these societies
underneath that is a sense of attachment
we have to our mates and that's a
cultural Universal this capacity to love
the people we are reproducing with is a
wonderful quality that we have and is
seen everywhere there's one exception
which is the knob people of the
Himalayas who have a very very strong
cultural overlay that tries to stamp out
the two foreigners they seem like a very
promiscuous Society Marco Polo describes
them the communist so what they have is
it's a matrilineal society in which
women live with their match align with
their mothers and their sisters and
their aunts
and they and the men visit the household
for furtive sexual encounters and the
women will pick who they want to have
sex with and it's not uncommon for a
woman to have had sex with every man in
the village and in nearby villages and
and the women have total control over
who they have sex with it the the the
the the the the men are seen as as doing
a service being nice to the women by
having sex with them and the children
that are born live in that household but
even in this society this whole
elaborate set of cultural rules about
this behavior is suppressing an innate
desire to be together and so the
forbidden behavior in this society is to
is to run away forsaking all others so
two people can be together this is the
forbidden desire and and they do some
couples like say I just want to love you
and to hell with the society that forces
me to be promiscuous ah we're gonna just
be you and me and they run away to be
together and in all of these different
cases you talk about how what kind of
local conditions that might persist over
centuries but kind of shape all of this
stuff yes yes so so but anyway but but
the thing is there is no doubt there's
tremendous cultural variation and in
fact one of the arguments that I like to
make or point out is the very fact that
we are a cultural animal and that we are
capable of manifesting this cultural
variation is itself a capacity we
evolved to have we evolved the capacity
to learn socially to acquire and
transmit information and to teach each
other this is very rare in the animal
kingdom so for example a little fish in
the sea can learn that if it sees the
light it can swim up and they'll be food
there
that's just individual learning social
learning is when you learn from someone
but some other organism is doing so I
can put my hand in the fire and learn
that it's hot and pull it out or you can
put your hand in the fire I see that you
burn yourself i acquire almost as much
knowledge about the badness of fire but
pay none of the price that's social
learning but we furthermore of all the
capacity to teach I take you and I teach
you about stuff and this allows us to
cumulate knowledge across time it's the
root of our capacity for culture so I
actually would
the problem on its head and I would say
this seeming variation that you see this
this not seeming this actual variation
you see is itself a part of the social
suite we've evolved the ability to teach
and learn from each other tell me about
your kind of intellectual genealogy or
influences because this type of applying
evolution you know not strictly but kind
of in a in a metaphoric way but in a
real way strikes made you know Friedrich
High talked about there but then there's
a variety of obviously evolutionary
biologists who talked about it where you
know what are the roots of this for you
well I've been trained both and then in
the in the biological and the social
sciences I'm a physician and a
sociologist I was a hospice doctor for
many years I took care of people who
were dying and I also was trained in
statistics and in computational sciences
and the work I've done in my lab over
the last 20 years has been at the
intersection of the biological social
and computational sciences and I mean
that I don't know how much you want to
know of the sequence of ideas there are
lots of I mean though there were my
teachers who I could name who people
might or might not recognize and of
course there'd all the various thinkers
who would take all day to list all the
various people various scientists
biologists social scientists
philosophers historians anthropologists
economists it goes on and on and and one
of the things that I I try to do as best
I can as a scholar is to try to
integrate as much information about as
many fields as possible but I but I
began my career as a as a as someone who
was investigating decision making in my
physicians in difficult circumstances
initially in the intensive care unit and
I became very interested in prognosis
how people predict well how doctors
predict what's gonna happen to patients
this in part related to my own life
experience as a young person growing up
with a chronically ill ultimately
terminally ill mother you know my whole
childhood was obsessed with when is she
gonna live or die so you know I was
obsessed with prognosis from a young age
I became a hospice doctor which I think
was counter phobic you know I was afraid
of my mother's death so what do you do
you go and expose yourself to death all
the time
and so I spent the first few years of my
career studying prognostication and then
I became interested in how to improve
the care of the dying in our society we
still do a terrible job caring for the
dying half of Americans die in pain it
should be a national travesty yeah and I
started looking for ways to fix that and
then my wife came to me my wonderful
wife in nineteen when was it it was
about 1995 or 1996 and she said to me
look this is getting ridiculous you
spend your whole day studying death and
destruction could you please study
something nicer and I was trying to
think of well what could I do that was
sort of you know evolutionary based on
the interests and strengths that I had
so I decided to study the widowhood
effect which is sort of when I just gone
to England and someone told me a joke
there I got into Saint Christopher's
Hospice where Cicely Saunders the sort
of the founding hospice of the hospice
movement and and one person there told
me a joke about how the department of
vital statistics they called it hatch
match and dispatch so birth marriage and
death and and I was studying dispatch I
couldn't study hatch so I figured I'd
study matched so I started studying the
widowhood effect which was the increased
probability of the recent dying of a
broken heart the fact that when your
partner dies your risk of death goes up
I spent five years studying that and
that got me into social networks and
then beginning about almost 20 years ago
now eighteen years ago now I started
studying human social interactions
starting with pairs of couples where
actually anyway so that's a little bit
of a history more than you probably well
you know it's fascinating and you know
at one point you write that humans are
pre-wired to make a particular kind of
society one full of love friendship
cooperation and learning to bring it to
kind of the contemporary moment you are
outside of your academic peers you're
best known for starring in a video where
a bunch of students are screaming and
yelling at you as that's not quite a
community of cooperation love and
learning and one oh what what is going
on do you think I'm either on the
college campus and not to make too much
out of that one instance but and not
simply about students but intellectually
this idea that while we have a common
you know
both have individual differences and a
common humanity these this seems to be
nobody's nobody's talking this way
what's what's going on all right well I
would I would stridently defend the
principle that we have a shared humanity
and that in fact that's the vehicle by
which we can come to understand each
other because if you don't think that if
you think that my superficial traits
define my beliefs and my ability to
empathize or see the world then why are
we even talking you know why do we talk
across lines though the whole idea in my
view is is that we have a shared
humanity we have the capacity for
empathy communication sympathy granting
goodwill the capacity to teach and learn
from each other and that these these
innate qualities that we have equip us
with a capacity to communicate with each
other otherwise if you don't believe
that if you don't believe in our common
humanity if you don't believe in the
shared humanity of all people why don't
we all just retreat to our corners and
not bother to interact at all first
point second point I think there is a
serious problem in our society right now
with certain liberal fundamental liberal
principles I would put among those
principles things that our founding
fathers saw and that many other
societies have also instantiate 'add for
example the freedom of assembly or the
freedom of speech now if you think about
those bill of rights type qualities that
the founding fathers they are actually
built on even though their enlightenment
principles they're built on a deep
evolutionary heritage I mean we've been
talking about friendship which relates
to the freedom of assembly we're a group
living species we like to pick our
friends the founding fathers knew better
than to try to push against that we like
to teach and learn from each other this
is the source of our wisdom in fact it's
the source of our wealth in fact it's
the source of our survival the fact that
human beings can live in more varied
environments than any other animal I
think other than ants so we have the
social conquest of the earth our species
has spread out to live everywhere from
the equator to the poles how did we do
that we do that because of our capacity
for culture we do that because of our
capacity to teach and learn from each
other so if we do not foster a society
of free speech a society in which we
able to openly communicate with each
other we are in a sense swimming against
this foundational reality is it is it
that things are worse now than they ever
were or is it that because I you know
some people with some critics of the
university would say well you got back
40 or 50 years there weren't a lot of
different types of people on campus you
know the road there were white men yes
that was it and that what we're seeing
now is there are more different voices
yes things have to change or so how do
we get to a place where it's not just
screaming matches or saying no to
academic freedom or to intellectual
heteros I think I think the challenge is
I totally endorse and support the
democratization of admissions at
American universities I I think these
are institutions which belong to all I
think any student coming to any school
should feel this is my place
I belong here I have every right to this
just like I feel like any person now we
have in our society we have often
breached those ideals alas we have a
long history of that you know we say the
justice is blind
we know that justice has not been blind
there's been discriminatory practices
with respect to for example if you're a
minority group you didn't get equal
justice under the law we had the
principle which i think is really
admirable and we've progressively gotten
better our courts are less and less
prejudiced against minority groups for
example and I think the same thing holds
for example with our universities it is
we have a principle of free and open
expression so I think and and we a
commitment to a reasoned discourse
evidence-based instruction and debate a
kind of civil kind of commitment to open
expression these are all foundational
principles so I think what we need to do
is as we appropriately democratize and
open up the the the kinds of people that
are coming to these institutions as well
we should is inculcate in them a
commitment to these beliefs welcome this
is a ancient and wonderful heritage that
we have a heritage devoted to these
these phenomenal worth defending liberal
principles this commitment to reason for
example this commitment to free
expression make them your own and one of
the hardest challenges I faced when I
was at Yale back then as you were
alluding to
is I had a young woman I think she was
Native American and she said to me in a
public venue she said these these
constitutional liberties that you Revere
these principles that you Revere were of
no use to my people
they've been around for a long time but
they were no use to people that looked
like me what say you to that and it was
a really hard question and in the moment
I couldn't think of an answer because of
course she was right you know we we had
these principles but we didn't honor
them as we should have and I think my
answer to her eventually in the form of
an essay that I wrote and in a form of
ideas that I have been thinking about in
response to her query is that you should
these principles are worth defending and
you should make them your own in fact
these are the principles you are using
right now to rectify the inequality that
was there before so this is I've been
using the Masters tools to both kind of
deconstruct the his house and then
rebuild it in a more inclusive way yes
and these tools you know you don't you
don't need to to be a Luddite right you
don't need to destroy you don't need to
throw the baby I don't know what the
right metaphor has the baby out with the
bathwater and I think you know I think
you see this right now for example with
there's a big debate happening right now
actually at Harvard about about the
commitment to the presumption of
innocence and that everyone deserves an
attorney so you know the and that and
that if you if you defend a criminal
maybe you're a bad person right and this
is there's a law professor who is
defending Harvey wines yeah and there
has been a petition to come out yes now
from my perspective we have a long
commitment in our society to drawing the
distinction between being a defense
attorney because everyone needs a
defense we believe that we have a system
of courts and laws and that you're
innocent until proven guilty and and we
have always seen being a defense
attorney as an honorable performance an
honorable occupation and if anything we
should be deeply suspicious of the idea
that oh if the police accused you you
must be guilty actually this false
belief has been used to the detriment of
downtrodden parts of our population
since time immemorial
quite the opposite so the commitment to
to these fundamental liberal principles
innocent until proven guilty
we have impartial judiciary that
everyone needs a lawyer there's nothing
wrong with being a lawyer even for
people who are accused of horrible
things freedom of expression civil
discourse voting right compromise and
these things unfortunately seem to be at
a kind of Abraham yeah what what do you
what do you think goes into that AB like
why is it happening and then what are
you know Beyond and it might just be
this reciting these and reminding people
of the value of this you know Hannah how
do we how do we get to a better place
where there is more academic heterodoxy
where there's more interest in trying
new ideas there's more interest in
having more discussions that are
inclusive rather than a few that are
very much in a kind of Jeremiah well I
mean the onion had a fantastic piece
that that said something like you know
universities strongly support
discussions of an idea you know like you
know just one ideas and we're all gonna
discuss that one idea we can you know I
I you know I don't have any kind of
special purchase on what ails our
society what causes the elements of our
society today the ailments we face are
elements we've faced before
a kind of splintering of a common wheel
a kind of us versus Democrat is zero-sum
politics a kind of loss of the ability
to compromise a kind of name-calling
which I find ridiculous you know I have
friends across the political spectrum I
have one libertarian friend who I adore
who is very deep thinker and really
challenges me and who you know I often
don't have answers to his ideas but it
makes me think actually I had a answer
by the way as always just end the Fed
and the Fed and then wasn't just gonna
but he yes but he has ideas like you
know he'll come up with you know we've
talked about all kinds of things with
him everything from arguments about the
private ownership of roads to for
example to whether black males should be
illegal or not and what is the reason we
make
make it a crime actually and you know
he'll he'll put me on my back feet I
think anyway my point is not him
specifically although he is a very smart
and and man who challenges my thinking a
lot my point is is that by exposing
oneself to many political beliefs you
know the famous mill statement he who
knows only his own side of the case
knows little of it if you aren't being
challenged if you aren't debating other
people with very dissimilar views you
don't really understand your case and so
I think this kind of stridency and in
fact even in martial arts you know you
why do you bow to your opponent you
thanking your opponent right your
opponent is a source of learning from
you and so you know I really believe
these ideas I'm not just saying them and
and I learned more from arguing with
people who I disagree with and I enjoy
agreeing with my friends of course
everyone does but anyway so I think that
we have to the we were identifying so
what ails our society is this lack of
compromise lack of tolerance all of this
stuff we've had this before I don't
think this will last forever but I don't
have any special insights into why we're
going through that phase again or when
it might end well typically these things
don't last more than half a generation
you know I think ten years maybe or 15
years we'll have this and then you know
we'll sort of sort it out
it'll be like after the Hundred Years
War there was peace of Europe for a
while well we will leave it there thank
you so much we've been talking about
Nicholas Christakis he's the author most
recently a blueprint the evolutionary
origins of a good society thanks for
talking Nick thank you for having me for
reason i'm nicholas me